[Music]
hi my secret is i'm uh a burstophile i'm
sexually attracted to like stuff like
murderers and like serial killers like
fictional or like real life
and like for me it's like the violence
gets me off
and uh
i'm pretty much on the sadistic side i'm
just weird like that and a lot of it's
expressed through my art
[Music]
okay so
one time i had this ex that
cheated on me with some random girl i
found out who the girl was started
talking to her
and i started dating her as well as the
talking to my ex still and i found out
that she had a boyfriend so i ended up
dating him as well so i end up dating
all three of them at the same time and
they didn't even know
when i was 16 i had a roommate
that she spoke english as well but her
mother language was russian
and most of the kids in our boarding
school spoke russian as well including
her friends so they would always come to
our room and they would speak russian to
each other and look at me and giggle
i had a feeling they were saying things
about me but i wasn't sure
and then one time i got pink eye from
another kid in school and every time
they came they would like make gestures
to their eyes and look at me and laugh
and i was getting a little upset so one
night she slept at her friend's room and
i was alone so i
rubbed my face on her pillow a couple of
times with the pink eye
hoping she would get it too and she did
eventually i honestly don't feel that
bad about it i they stopped making fun
of my pink eye after that so
that's my secret
okay
when i was a little kid when i was first
learning how to clip my toenails and my
mom stopped doing it i
finally learned i didn't know what it
taste uh what it tasted like a toenail
so
the first time i did it i ate all 10 of
my toenails
[Music]
sometimes i think
that
i should have been a man
because i'm so dominant so when i see
women it's like
damn shorty if i was a man i would have
told her ass up
[Music]
in 2009 i probably was the only one of
my friends to buy justin bieber's album
but it was worth it
okay so my secret is just about every
time i'm in an elevator by myself
without fail i'll pretend like i'm
opening and closing the doors using my
mind kind of like the force and i'm also
making the elevator go up and down and
using my mind as well
that's my secret
[Music]
i feel like one secret i do have would
be
that i'm kind of afraid of rejection i
can give an example of this too uh
anytime i would shoot my shot with a
beautiful
woman
or a companion it would be like either
three reasons why they would say no
either they don't feel the same way they
feel like i'm more of a friend to them
and they don't really want to lose that
relationship or it's because they just
see me like a brother and i kind of
understand that but at the same time
it's just like ah
[Music]
i have commitment issues
very scared of marriage i don't trust
nobody
i feel like everyone's out for self
mainly because i grew up assad
and
i've seen what's been done to a lot of
males i don't want it done to me
[Music]
people think i'm
a really happy person and that i have my
life together
but i actually really struggled to get
out of bed every morning and i have to
tell myself that it will be okay
otherwise i won't leave
my apartment for days at a time
so
it's not always what you see
[Music]
i already told everybody this but uh
when i went to boot count my girlfriend
well it was my girlfriend she sent me a
letter and broke up with me but i ain't
crying for nobody in the uh in a
barracks but when i went to sleep i
cried myself to sleep
[Music]
i sometimes pretend to be afraid of
horror films
because i don't know sometimes i just
want to be held by my boyfriend but i'm
really not scared because i really love
horror films
[Music]
i thought i was going to kill myself
five years ago so i didn't make a plan
for my future and now i don't know what
i'm doing
um so one time when i was maybe five or
six i was in the grocery store with my
mom
and we were at the cash register and i
stole a pack of
hubba bubba bubble gum and i got home
and i felt so deeply guilty for having
stolen that it sat in the drawer of my
bathroom
for years and years and years and i
never
ate it and then like a couple of years
ago i finally threw it out and i could
never bring myself to eat it because i
felt so guilty
[Music]
so my secret is
basically i got
locked up for domestic that i didn't do
so what happened was our argument had
happened i wasn't from this particular
town so i was like you know what i'm
just gonna go because i really don't
like confrontation so as i was trying to
leave this person was kind of throwing
stuff and pretty much i didn't fight or
not whatnot but um i think that it was
going too far past words so
i called the cops for my protection
and
i finally found a way to get outside
and i waited on a cops again i wasn't
from this particular area i am from
chicago
and
the cops came
the gentleman barely questioned me i
actually did have
red marks on my neck and everything the
next thing i know another cop had showed
up
they asked for my id
next thing i know
i'm getting handcuffed
the guy didn't even tell me what i was
getting handcuffed for i'm like
panicking i got ptsd so i'm sitting here
like why am i getting locked up i called
you guys for my protection i just wanted
to walk away
grab my belongings i've never been
locked up i've never been in trouble
come to find out from
other people
that live in this particular area this
particular city that
if you look a certain way
and you're from chicago
you get looked at different um too many
people view chicago as being
bad if you're dressed in an urban manner
like they judge the book before getting
to know you so
unfortunately i was locked up for three
days
had a lot of nightmares
got through it everything was dropped i
was clear the judge even apologized to
me
um
it's messed up though because
i grew up on when you were in trouble
called the cops now i think differently
and the sad part is i know all cops
ain't bad
but this is my secret
i got out of it and i got out of it
because i chose positivity and i chose
to go forward and not backwards
[Music]
i found out that
slavery still exists we are told that it
doesn't it is most times shown away from
it is avoided
the fact that it being mentioned is
ridiculed but it actually still exists
through the prison system i
unfortunately became a victim of a pen
myself
for three and a half years for an event
that never took place
and i depended on the system
trusted the system
in order to
find the truth
and deal with the truth and
unfortunately i was put back in the
position
to be made a slave again
we think that it has stopped because
there is no more cotton fields we think
that it has stopped because no one is
hanging from trees we think that has
stopped because there's no more
ropes or noises being made we think that
is stopped because there's no one
wearing hoods the same clansmen or
anything of that nature
but it's actually now
with a pen
and a sail
that has made slavery continue without
the actual the usual
the evident
that will cause us to see it clearly i
was
arrested and
put in jail incarcerated for a crime
that i allegedly committed caused me to
be sitting in jail for three years and
three months
begging for trial no evidence and the
only thing that they can come up with
after three and a half years
was a picture
of a finger
with a scratch on it with no scantron
and no other evidence to find me guilty
of something
so i wouldn't walk away with nothing
as again i came up in the urban area
i was taught to watch out for gunmen for
rapists for thieves for murderers
i was never taught to watch the pen
as of today
i learned the power of the pen
and the ones who use it
[Music]
hey everyone for those of you who are
new my name is thoria and i'm the girl
behind the camera i actually plan on
taking the series to new city every
month starting with today's episode you
probably noticed it was filmed in
chicago and next month it's going to be
new york so stay tuned for that make
sure to subscribe and hit the
notification bell so you'll be notified
every time i have a new episode up and
follow me on instagram i'll be posting
more on there as i'm traveling so
that'll be fun
as always thank you guys for everything
i love you all and i'll see you next
time